[موسيقى]
في كتابه احوال الطيبين الصالحين عند
الموت يروي سيد ابن حسين العفاني عن فقيه
المدينه عبد الله بن ذكوان ان خالدا ابن
الوليد رضي الله عنه لما احتضر بكى وقال
لقيت كذا وكذا زحفا وما في جسدي شبر الا
وفيه ضربه بسيف او رميه بسهم وها انا اموت
على فراشي فلا نامت اعين الجبناء هذه
الجمله الاخيره تحولت الى حكمه عربيه
متوارثه فحواها ان انتهاء الاجل هو السبب
الحقيقي للموت يدرك الناس ولو اختبؤوا في
بروج مشيده او تخلفوا عن نداء الحق والوا
واجب فهذا سيف الله المسلول خالد لم يمت
بسيوف الاعداء الى
العناوين القسام ديليفري خدمه توصيل
القذائف الى
الدبابات ضابط رفيع في الناتو جيش اسرائيل
وقع في فخ
غزه تل ابيب تحتفي بمحلل عربي يتحدث عن
حماس ومستشفى الش
الف ضحيه مدني لقتل مقاوم ولم يتاكد
الاحتلال من
قتله وزير تراث اسرائيل يحافظ على تراثها
ويهدد غزه بقنبله
النوويه المطبع المؤيدون للعدوان السنه
احتياط في روايه
الاحتلال السلطه الفلسطينيه تتحضر
لمليونيه لا حول ولا قوه الا
[موسيقى]
بالله مرحبا هل يصح هل يصح ان تنافس
المقاومه الفلسطينيه شركات توصيل الطلبات
فتطلق في غزه خدمه ضربات لتوصيل الطلقات
الى
الدبابات هذا ما فعلته حرفيا القسام
ديليفري بدبابه اسرائيليه وصوره القسام
رياليتي تلفجن وكاد رجل التوصيل ان يطلب
توقيع طاقم الدبابه على استلامهم طلبيه
وجبه الياسين 105 الساخنه والتي تؤكل لمره
واحده واخيره يكتب مراقب
فلسطيني بينم سدا ومن خلفهم سدا فاغشيناهم
فهم
يبصرون هل مقاومه الاحتلال عمل ارهابي
منذ فجر التاريخ اقدمت دول ونادرا عصابات
على احتلال دول اخرى وعلى مدى العصور مجدت
المجتمعات على اختلاف معتقداتها طليعه
محرريها من الاحتلالات الذين قدموا
ارواحهم لامم دون منه او حساب هذا في
ثقافه الشعوب اما في القانون الدولي
فالتقرير يجيب المقاومه عمل شرعي في
القانون الدولي واحتمال انتصارها يرتبط
بعاملين طبيعه الاحتلال طبيعه الارض
المحتله وشعبها والاختلاف الديني مع
المحتل يزيد حده المقاومه خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى دعا الكهنه الارثوذكس في
صربيا للمقاومه ضد الاحتلال النمساوي
المجري لكن الاحتلال الاكثر قسوه هو
الاستيطاني الاحلالي مثل استعمار
الاوروبيين لامريكا الشماليه واستراليا
ياتي المستعمر فيبني مستوطنات ويطرد سكان
الاصليين او يقتلهم ويحل مكانهم لذلك اسمه
احلالي وقد نرى في محتل واحد كل صفه
المحتل الذي يدفع لمقاومه اكبر ونرى في
شعب تم احتلاله كل الوصفات اللازمه
لمقاومه اشد في عصرنا الكيان المحتل
الوحيد لدوله وشعب على وجه الارض هو
اسرائيل رئيس حكومه الاحتلال بنيامين
نتنياهو يعترف بخسائر مؤلمه في غزه لكن
بعض ابواق اسرائيل متعدده اللغات ومنها
العربيه اللغه العربيه تقول لمن لا يرى
نصرا لاسرائيل حتى الان الا على الاطفال
والنساء انت تستعيد سيره احمد سعيد وصوت
العرب في مصر ايام الهزائم المحلاه بالسكر
الاصطناعي الذي انتجه وما يزال اعلام بعض
الانظمه
الصت
الاعلامي الاسرا اه يتالم لفرح العرب بالم
قاده الاحتلال ويقول لهم بالعبر ولك
بهدلتونا وضحكوا العرب علينا ورفعت
معنويات الارهابيين الشرفاء في القاموس
العربي السور
لر
رمش
ب حكومه تل ابيب عملت بنصيحه ايدي باخفاء
الحقائق المؤلمه فاعتقلت الصحفي العبري
افرائيم
موردخاي بعدما صرح بانه شاهد الجثث
المقدسه بالعشر
للجنود الاسرائيليين في احد مشافي تلبيب
لكن سرطه الاحتلال لم تعتقل مراسله فوكس
نيوز الامريكيه المرافقه لجيش الاحتلال
حين افاد عن مقتل 20 من الجنود في كمين
واحد
بكل الاحوال ابو عبيده الناطق باسم كتائب
القسام لا يوافق اطلاقا على ما يعلنه جيش
الاحتلال من حجم خسائره البشريه ويقول
العدد اكبر بكثير مما يعلن وسنجعل غزه
لعنه التاريخ على جيش الاحتلال ابو عبيده
يتكلم وكانه لم يسمع وعيد نتنياهو بسحق
حركه حماس صحيح انه الوعيد الاسرائيلي
الخامس من نوعه خلال السنوات الاخيره بحسب
ميشيل ياكوفليف نائب رئيس الاركان السابق
لحلف الناتو لكنها اسرائيل يا رجل التي
انتصرت على جيوش فلماذا ينذرها ضابط
الناتو من ان جيشها وقع في فخ غزه وان في
غزه مقاتلين يقون ل في سبيل قضيتهم وهذا
لاكن الاستهانه به
بحسب مش ابو
ع solution militaire cette guerre donc
la solution est politique il va les isra
en particulier des concessions et
maintenant hamas leel probl militaire et
human et politique qu' va trouver chose
oui je suis pas un grand connaisseur
des islamistes je je je pense ce sont
des des combattants qui ont autant envie
de mourir que que le lire en francea son
job ceci dit ils se bont pour ce qu'il
ctre leur cause pour ce qu'il consid le
cause هذا الا واحد من اهم المحل العسري
العرب هو الجال صفوه الزات الذت له هذه
راءه لطوفان الاقصى في اخر ايام حياته
رحمه الله انا اعتقد انهم اصيبوا اصابه
بالغه لم يشهدوها في تاريخهم دعني اقول لك
ان الثلاثه ايام
الاولى ان يقتحم الفلسطينيين بهذا الاداء
الرائع السياج الحدودي في اكثر من 80 صغره
وفي تقريبا سبعه معابر رئيسيه ان يصلوا
الى الى مستوطنه رعيم حيث مقر قياده فرقه
غزه وان ربما ثروا ضباط كبار فيها ربما
بلماس النوم ان يديروا معركه رائعه للغايه
في كرم ابو سالم يعني المزدحمه بالاليات
المضر مركاب ونمر وخلافه وان يدمروا هذا
الكم ان يصبوا حتى في الشمال الى معبر ارز
ومعسكر ارز ويؤدوا ايضا هذه الصور التي
نقلت اعتقد ان في هذه اللحظه علينا ان
نتذكر انه من الان وللابد كسرت نظريه او
عقيده الامن القوم الاسرائيل يقولون ان
حرب النظرات سهله وان من يتلقى ضرب العصي
ليس كمن يعدها وجمر النار يحرق مكانه فقط
فهل نستمع برويه الى المعذبين في غزه
الذين ورطه قائد المقاومه محممد
في حرب لا طاقه لهم بها ماذا يقولون للضيف
ولجن الضيف الله يحيك يا
ضيف يحمي جدودك يا
[موسيقى]
ضيف تعرف العامه حول العالم كلمه الله
اكبر التي شوهت معناها الايمانيه الراقي
بعض الممارسات الدخيله على الدين الان
اصبح العالم يعرف معنى كلمه الحمد لله بعد
سماعهم لها من اهل غزه وهم يرددونها على
السنتهم برغم كل
شيء الحمدله نصيبنا من الدنيا الحمد
لله شه ليش عايشين خساره في ربنا الله
خلقنا والله بياخدنا يفعل ما يريد واحنا
الحمد لله
صبين any footage of palestinian people
cursing jewish people or israel people
these are people of god know these
people were blessed by allah
himself such anable hope don't give
about life okay the only thing these
people fear is allah that's something
that people don't get to see of defin
not here in the west صبر اهل غزه وتمسكهم
بايمانهم وعقيدتهم القرانيه سيدفعنا الى
فهم الاسلام واعتناقه
يقولون
[موسيقى]
لم يسبق لمحتل ان تجرا على المستشفيات كما
فعلت وتفعل اسرائيل فهي دمرت كل شيء في
غزه المساجد والكنائس والمدارس والبنايات
وعينها الان على ما تبقى من
مستشفيات part of war machine this is of
operation a ground operation that was
conducted on the hospital revealed aun
was used for
infrastructures in qat
hosp هذه المزاعم كاذبه وفبركات من
الاحتلال ما ظهر في المقطع المصور هو فوها
لخزان مياه في الجهه الشرقيه من مستشفى
حمد للاطراف الصناعيه المعروف بالمستشفى
القطري مستشفى الشفاء كبرى مستشفيات غزه
يزعم جيش الاحتلال في كل عدوان ان قياده
حركه حماس تتحرك من خلاله وهذه فرضيه
ساذجه حول مستشفى مفتوح دون قيود لمليوني
انسان في قطاع غزه للاستشفاء والفحوص
والمراجعات الطبيه كل يوم فكيف يكون
عسكريا امام كل الناس وليس كل الناس مع
حماس بالطبع بالتاكيد مادس جيلبير الطبيب
النرويجي في مستشفى الشفاء على سبيل
المثال ليس حمساويه هو يشهد للتاريخ
والانسانيه انه عمل في مستشفى الشفاء ل 16
عاما لم يرى خلالها اي قاعده عسكريه لا
فوق ولا تحت ولم تفرض عليه اي قيود حول
تحر
في المى medal doct civan i been all
around in shif hospit for 16 years i've
been walking freely everywhere i've
taken pictures and videos i have talked
to anybody to patients and to staff i've
even been sleeping in in the shifa
hospital and i have never seen any signs
of any military command c in shifa
الاسرائيليه حول عسكره المستشفيات تعتمد
على اكذوبه المساد وترهات الجواسيس لكن
الاعلام العبري احتفى هذا الاسبوع بسقط
مدويه لمحلل عسكري لبناني ناطق بالعربيه
يدعى رياض قهوجي فقالت صفحه اسرائيل في
الخليج ان اباطيل حماس لا تنطلي حتى على
العرب فالمحل العسكري على قناه العربيه
يؤكد ان مشفى الشفاء يضم مركز قياده لدواع
غزه كما قالوا هذه المنطقه والتي تحتوي
ايضا على على مستشفى الشفاه هي مركز
القياده الاساسي هو
تعتبر نبض وقلب قياده حركه حماس وهي ما
تحاول اسرائيل الوصول اليه ان تمكنت او
اقله تشديد الخناق ومحاصرته قدر الامكان
السقطه الاولى للقهوجي فقد رصد مؤخرا وهو
يطلق على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وصف داعش
الذي عممه المساد الاسرائيلي على
المستويين السياسي والاعلامي في تل ابيب
لكن القهوجي صحح لاحقا معتبرا خطيئته
الكلاميه سبق لسان حيث ستضطر اسرائيل
لادخال المشاه
لمواجهه مقاتلي داعش يعني وجها لوجه
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وبعد تغريده القهوجي
تمسك بروايته حول حماس ومستشفى الشفاء
واعرب مراسل الشؤون العربيه في القناه
الحاديه عش العبريه روعي كيس عن دهوله لما
اعتبره تبني رياض قهوجي الروايه السرديه
الاسرائيليه اكثر من مره باغوت
الغبع بمش
ر
هذه المنطقه والتي تحتوي اي مستشفى
شفز القياده الاساسي هو
تعتبر الب وقلب قيا
رس
صه اتد ير حد خل دقيقتين
بضربتين فضحيه مدنيه بين شهيد ومصاب
ومفقود بحجه ملاحقه قيادي واحد من
المقاومه ولم يتاكد من قتله لكنه متاكد من
مجزرتي قتل بها مئات
المدنيين
من قال لمذيع الس ان ان ان اسرائيل تابه
اصلا بالمدنيين محاضر اسرائيلي يدعى
الياهو يوس يفترض انه من نخبه المثقفين
يحسمها وبدون تردد اقتلوا الجميع فلا يوجد
ابرياء او مدنيون في غزه
يقولون
مشمع بقلب ام حني بلا زغره ودعت والده
جندي اسرائيل ابنها قبل توجهه الى القتال
واوسطه ماما حبيبي ما توفر حدا اقتل
الاطفال والنساء والجميع وتضيف سنقصف
المستشفيات ايضا فنحن مركز العالم ليست
غزه فقط بل الشرق الاوسط كله لنا هذا ما
وعدنا به الله تقول فهل يستمع اليها
المطبع
محاميه اسرائيليه من اصل فرنسي تتمتع باذن
عنفيه لا تستمتع الا بصوت القصف الهمج
trs couch de ville de
gaz vo
rs rid veut 2 k de gaza ent
malos voil on esp juste que n
seulement seulement des explosions sur
gaza de notre
aviation ال الاسرائيليه لا تزال ضيفه
دائمه على اعلام الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
وقيمها العلمانيه هل يعقل ان نساوي بين
الاطفال الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين سؤال استنكاري من محلله
سياسيه فرنسيه كيوت تنافس في منسوب
اللطافه عندها اعتى الوحوش نحن لا نتحدث
عن تمساحه ولا عن معزايه حاش وكلا
فالبدائل
لتهرب ا هذا mais ces enfants ne mour pas
en ayant l'impression qu'en face d'eux
l'humanite d' ce qui est horrible c'est
d'images enfants qui avaient 8 9 10 ans
ces femmes qui sont partis en ortant
comme derni image une image d'in d'r et
de mpr de ceux qui
رل المدنين
الفلسطينين كما قل اسلافه هن
امريكا
هذا التحشيد الاعلامي الاسرائيلي
والامريكي والاوروبي ل شيطنه الفلسطينيين
من اطفالهم الرضع الى العجائز في
المستشفيات هل يبرر لوزير التراث
الاسرائيلي عمي حي الياهو دعوته او اعتب
ان القاء قنبله نوويه على غزه حل ممكن
مسؤولون اسرائيليون لم يتوقع ان تصل
النذاله بوزير الى ان يضحي باسرى اسرائيل
في غزه وليس بمليوني فلسطيني كل هذا
الدمار غير كاف بالنسبه لوزير التراث
الاسرائيلي عمي حي الياهو قال ان احد
الخيارات في الحرب الجاريه اسقاط قنبله
ذريه على قطاع غزه مضيفا ان قطاع غزه يجب
الا يبقى على وجه الارض مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو سارع الى
تعليق مشاركه وزير التراث امي خاي الياهو
في اجتماعات الحكومه حتى اشعار اخر
والصادم في الامر بان الجدل في اسرائيل
ليس من باب تعارضه مع اخلاق البشر عبر
اباده شعب كامل بل لانه بحسب المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يضع المحتجزين الاسرائيليين
بخطر ويسيء لذويهم من محاسن الصدف ان
الياهو الارهابي هو وزير التراث المعبر
بصدق عن تراث اسرائيل العقائدي في تشريع
جرائم الاباده يعلق معلق ويضيف ليش هل بقي
شيء تقصفه في غزه بالنووي هو لسه بده يهدد
دمرونا ده اصلا المتفجرات اللي رموها
علينا اكثر تعد اكثر من قمله نوويه ما ظل
في مكان اصلا اجمع اللي ضربوا علينا
بتلاقي قنبلتين قنبلتين النووي يعني
يضربها الثانيه بالمره وخلص ويح راسه عشان
احنا وياه نرتاح من الدنيا هذ كلها يتفرج
يشوف الدمار اللي احنا فيه كل يوم بنضرب
علينا القنبله نويه هو لسه بستنى انه
قنبله النوويه ما كل يوم برمنا جزء من
قبله
[موسيقى]
النوويه علاقه طرديه بين استمرار الحرب
وانهيار الثقه في نتنياهو اظهرها استطلاع
اجري بعد عره ايام على انطلاق الحرب يكشف
ان قرابه 40% من الشارع يقف خلف حكومته
صحيفه معارف الاسرائيليه اكدت هذه العلاقه
بعد اجرائها استطلاعا جديدا اظهر انهيار
اسهم نتنياهو بين الاسرائيليين حيث يعتقد
27% من العينه المختاره انه الانسب لرئاسه
الحكومه معظم الاسرائيليين اليوم لا
يؤيدون بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته الحربيه
لكن فرقه سواقط التطبيع الاعمى تؤيد عدوان
حكومه تل ابيب على
الفلسطينيين يقال ان بعض الفاشلين يسعون
باي ثمن للفت الانظار اليهم علما ان اكثر
شيء يلفت انظارنا في الاماكن العامه
هيض حتى نذهب اليها دون سؤال احد هذه
المقدمه لا تمت بصله الى الفيديو المرفق
فالد هي مرافق لا نستغني عنها في الحياه
وكذلك تفصل بين المراه والرجل اما نحن
فجمعنا هما في فيديو واحد كلنا الحقيقه
يعني يجب ان نقف الى جانب اسرائيل فيما
تفعله وفي ملاحقتها الحماس وبالعكس و
نساعدها في ذلك حرب تاخدها اسرائيل ضد
الارهاب بالنيابه عن منطقه الشرق الاوسط
هذا افضل توصيف للحرب التي تجري الان قطر
ساعدت في انشاء في انشاء منظومه حماس
الارهابيه كل هذه المجهود الحربي اللي
قامت بحماس هو جاء من اموال قطريه اكثر
الاعلام اللي يدعم حماس هو موجود في
اوروبا وفي قطر اعلام يحرض العالم العربي
يحرض الشباب العربي ضد الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه في المقابل الاكاديمي السعودي
المعروف خالد الدخيل يسال المعترفين
باسرائيل كيف تعترفون بدوله حدودها
الجغرافيه مفتوحه هل تعرف ان اسرائيل ترفض
تعين حدود له على الاطلاق على الاطلاق على
حدود انت تعترف بدوله حدودها مفتوحه ش
الكلام وهذا نظام الامم المتحده
بالمناسبه عشان اعترف بالدوله لازم اعرف
حدودها ش هي يعني وين تنتهي حدودها وانتم
تلتقط هواتفكم لمتابعه مواقف المغردين
احذروا الفتان من وحده المساد الاسرائيلي
8000 و2 احضروه وحثوا البلوك في وجوههم
شخصين دخلوا عندي على الحساب في التعليقات
الاول حاط صوره فلسطين بدون مناسبه دخل
كتب تعليق عن الاردن وتاريخ الاردن وحضاره
الاردن ونظام الاردن مسبات مسبات مسبات
الثاني كان حاط صوره علم الاردن دخل رد
عليه وعيره وسب عليه وقال له انت بلجيكي
وبعت لي قضيه قررت اني ادخل واعمل بلوك
للاثنين اللي سووا فتنه دخلت على الاول
عملت له بلوك طلعت لي رساله انه اذا بتعمل
بلوك لهذا الشخص رح نعمل البلوك لكل
حساباته الثانيه في اسماء اخرى قلت اوكي
كبست اوكي عملت له بلوك رجعت على الثاني
عشان اد اعمل له بلوك دور عليه دور عليه
دور عليه ما لقيته بعدين دخلت على القائمه
اللي فيها اسماء البلوك لقيته موجود هون
استغربت انه يعني انا ما عملت له بلوك شو
جابه هون على قائمه البلوك بعد تفكيره
صفنان اكتشفت انه هو نفس الشخص عنده
حسابين بدخل من حسابه الفلسطيني بب على
الاردن وبعدين بدخل من حسابه الاردني بب
على فلسطين وبيعمل فتنه اسمع يا سيدي في
وحده اسمها 8200 اسرائيليه فيها خليه
مستعربين بيحكوا عربي احسن مني ومنك في كل
مكان بتلاقيهم وفكرهم اصحابك حتى في
بتلاقيهم حاطين صور وتاريخ وكذا فبلغوا
عنهم ولا سكتوه بحسب التقارير ابدى الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي استعداده للمساعده في اداره قطاع
غزه بعد التخلص من حركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه
الفلسطينيه شفت شو طيب رح يساعد ولاول مره
منذ بدء الحرب في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
التقى بلينكن الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
الذي ابدى استعداده للمساعده في ادار قطاع
غزه بعد عزل حماس حسب مسؤول امريكي اخيرا
اعلن الناطق باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل
ابو ردينه عن الخطه باء للسلطه في رام
الله هذه الخطه هي مليونيه لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله فشاركوا فيها اثابكم الله
القرار الان هو وقف العدوان ومنع التهجير
اذا نجحنا في ذلك بمساعده الاشقاء العرب
ومساعده احرار العالم نكون قد خطونا خطوه
هامه نحو النصر واذ لم تنجحوا سيد نبيل
واذ لم تنجحوا واذ لم تنجحوا لا حول ولا
حول ولا قوه الا بالله اذا الخطه البديله
هي انه لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله لان ما
باليد حيله كما فهمت
[موسيقى]
فعلا ختاما يقال ان المشروع الاسرائيلي
لتوطين فلسطيني غزه في سيناء المصريه له
اب هو رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الاسبق
ورئيس قسم التخطيط في جيش الاحتلال
الجنرال جيورا ايلاند الذي خرج قبل ايام
على قومه
فافسدها بتدمير البيوت الهشه فوق رؤوس
ساكنيها فقال نحن لا نرى اي علامه على
انكسار حماس بل نشاهد انهم ينفذون عمليات
معقده ومنسقه بواسطه المسيرات وقذائف
الهون والصواريخ المضاده للدروع هؤلاء
ليسوا افرادا يحاربون من اجل انفسهم بل هم
منظومه تعمل وتتحرك ويسيطرون على اكثر من
80% من جوف الارض ويعرفون كيف يردون بسرعه
على ضرباتنا لذلك يختم جنرال اسرائيل فان
غزه ما زالت الهدف المحصن الاكبر
في العالم الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء